I'm going to show you the best way to
get at the root cause of those dark
circles underneath your eyes
it's called periorbital dark circles now
typically when you look this up you're
going to see a million different
remedies okay and they do work the
problem is they only work temporarily
you have to keep applying them over and
over and over
you can use kojic acid and you can use
vitamin C aloe vera niacinamide which is
a type of B3 or you can even use
cucumber extract or cucumbers so any of
these will work temporarily simply take
the remedy and rub it underneath your
eyes and give it you know some days or
even weeks so what do all of these have
in common they inhibit
melanin okay which causes this
pigmentation in your skin and that's
cool you can do that um there's probably
not a lot of side effects but I want to
talk about the two underlying root
causes to this problem so you can
actually permanently get rid of this now
the first one involves understanding
just a little bit about your hormone
system okay you have this little gland
in the brain called the pituitary and it
sends signals down through the body and
one of the tissues that it controls is
the adrenal glands you have two of them
deep into your abdomen okay the adrenal
glands produce a lot of different
hormones but there's one that is called
cortisol and that is a stress hormone so
the pituitary sends a signal down to the
adrenal when there's perceived stress
and that pituitary hormone is called
ACTH it hits the adrenal and then the
adrenal produces cortisol once cortisol
is produced that amount of cortisol that
is produced
reaches up to the pituitary and tells
the pituitary to turn off
to stop producing this circuit and so
now that ACTH can stop being activated
now it just so happens when you go
through a period of stress called a
chronic stress which could include
loneliness
losses or anything to raise your level
of cortisol like
synthetic cortisol prednisone
medications Etc what's going to happen
next is your body is going to develop
this cortisol resistance very similar to
insulin resistance and if you want to
look this up this is a real condition
okay it's called glucocorticoid receptor
resistance now what happens in this
situation
is because of the excess communication
coming down from that pituitary that
could be a bit too dangerous so your
receptors kind of shut down
and inhibit the absorption of cortisol
into the cells and this is a protective
mechanism what's going to happen next is
you're going to have a deficiency of
cortisol so the communication is being
sent but it's not being received so it's
kind of like talking to someone but
they're completely ignoring you so what
are you going to do you're going to
start shouting at them right eventually
you're going to start talking louder and
that's exactly what the pituitary starts
doing it starts to increase its level of
communication why because it's not
getting through okay
your pituitary thinks that you have a
cortisol deficiency but in reality it's
just resistance in the receptor it's
definitely deficiency but it's because
there's too much cortisol so anytime you
have too much ACTH you're going to have
a big spike in this other hormone called
melanocyte stimulating hormone and
that's where you get the increase in
melanin which is that darkening of your
skin and very commonly it can occur
right underneath your eyes now this is
the problem because not only are you
going to get this darkening underneath
your eyes
but you're going to have all the other
symptoms that come along with cortisol
resistance you see cortisol helps you
adapt to stress okay put your body into
a stress state to help you overcome a
stressful situation but now we have a
situation that we have stress but
unfortunately without the benefit of
cortisol so now you get more
inflammation in the body and that can
happen on the skin as other problems
you're more susceptible to infection
your immune system actually becomes very
dysfunctional
etc etc so what could be done with this
cortisol deficiency that's really
causing this problem number one you have
to do something about your stress you
have to reduce it in any way shape or
form and I'm talking about the actual
source of the stress no matter what it
is and to flush out the stress start
increasing regular aerobic exercise
where you're actually not producing a
lot of stress but you're running or
flushing out all this adrenaline and
cortisol out of the system
if you do physical work outside that is
even better than exercise because it
also relieves the mental component to
stress because it shifts your attention
to something else far too often when
someone works out and they're on the
treadmill whatever or at the gym
they're thinking about these stressful
moments at the same time unfortunately
so it's really sometimes hard to extract
the attention on that stress situation
okay the next thing is sleep okay get
more sleep take more naps go to bed
earlier sleep in later the next thing to
do and this is something that is a very
important in vitamin D3 okay I would
take probably 20 to 30 000 I use the
vitamin D3 vitamin D3 acts like cortisol
in the body but without the side effects
so it can give you some benefits of this
cortisol immediately magnesium is
probably one of the most important
minerals to take and then also limit the
amount of screen time you know looking
into the computer that can really strain
the eyes and it's just unfortunately not
very healthy even though we all do it
the next thing is reduce insulin okay
you see this in diabetics diabetics have
this condition where they have kind of
dark velvety skin in the folds of their
body sometimes around their neck armpits
and what's happening is they have high
levels of insulin okay and insulin
resistance
that is Raising this melanocyte
stimulating hormone and this is a really
easy one to correct if you understand
what's happening all you have to do
is bring your carbs down to 20 grams or
less per day and then just not eat so
frequently skip the snacks
skip breakfast and just have two or even
one meal a day okay you combine that
with lowering your stress and you will
see a lightning of these dark circles
under your eye which will then remain
absent I have a lot more to say on this
topic if you haven't seen this video on
stress you should check it out I put it
up right here